Alright. Although there might have been some new terms for some of you out there
in this lesson, hopefully the concept map wasn't
too hard to piece together. Let's start here
with pharmacogenomics, which studies how the genome
affects our response to drugs. Now pharmacogenomics wants
to minimize toxicity and maximize efficacy of drugs.
The ability to do that enhances personalized medicine.
Pharmacogenomics is one main way that we can
achieve more personalized medicine. Now obviously the genome
contains many various alleles which we've learned about
in. Many lessons, particularly if you want a refresher,
lessons 3, 4, and 6 would be a good place to check out. But in this lesson
we learn that alleles that affect pharmacokinetics have
to do with pathways about the metabolism of drugs.
Whereas alleles affecting pharmacodynamics are about pathways that are
target effects of the specific drugs. Together, the pharmacodynamics and
pharmacokinetics influence our efficacy and toxicity of particular drugs
that are at the center of our study in pharmacogenomics.